wir befinden uns im Jahr 2022 nach
Christus Deutschland gilt als lupenreine
Demokratie alle Menschen sind überzeugte
Demokraten ganz Deutschland nein ein
unbeugsamer Teil im Osten des Landes
hört nicht auf Widerstand zu leisten
okay diese kleine Asterix und Obelix
Referenz ist natürlich eine humorvolle
Zuspitzung unsererseits und ein Blick
auf die Ossis oder Anführungszeichen
durch die super arrogante Wessi Brille
ganz klar sie hat aber trotzdem einen
Kern denn immer wieder kursieren
Vorurteile über die politische
Einstellung der Menschen in
Ostdeutschland die Ostdeutschen werden
dabei als einheitliche Masse
wahrgenommen die Demokratie feindlich
sei aber stimmt das überhaupt ticken Ost
und West in dieser Frage so verschieden
stehen die Menschen in Ostdeutschland
der Demokratie wirklich kritischer
gegenüber als die Menschen in den
westdeutschen Bundesländern in den alten
Bundesländern die man früher gesagt hat
und wenn ja aus welchen Gründen die
Forschungsgruppe waren hat sich das mal
genauer angeschaut in dieser Grafik hier
seht ihr deutlich die Demokratie
zufrieden Mehrheit der ostdeutschen
bleibt konstant unter den Werten der
westdeutschen und bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl gab es vor allem einen
starken Unterschied zwischen Ost und
West das Ergebnis der AFD der
Alternative für Deutschland 20,5 Prozent
zu 8,2%. das ist deutlich also Frage
geklärt nee so einfach ist es natürlich
nicht welchen Einfluss die deutsche
Wiedervereinigung auf diese Debatte hat
und die unterschiedlich Ost- und West
tatsächlich sind das seht ihr jetzt in
diesem Video
[Musik]
eine Umfrage der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
zur politischen Zufriedenheit vom
September 2022 veranschaulicht die
Ostdeutschen sind insgesamt
unzufriedener mit der Demokratie als die
Westdeutschen aber was heißt das genau
lehnt etwa mehr als die Hälfte der
ostdeutschen die Demokratie komplett ab
Andrea Wolf von der Forschungsgruppe
Wahlen erklärt wie die Antworten
einzuordnen sind ganz wichtig bei dieser
Fragestellung ist aber dass wir nach dem
Funktionieren der Demokratie fragen wir
fragen nicht nach der Staatsform sondern
wie funktioniert das Wieste Output
dieser der Politik der der Regierung und
hier sehen wir schon das ist dauerhaft
unter dem Westniveau liegt es gibt
einfach
größere Unzufriedenheit es gibt auch
mehr mehr Kritik klappt mehr als die
Hälfte der Befragten ostdeutschen ist
also eher unzufrieden mit der
politischen Leistung der regierenden
innerhalb des Systems also dem
funktionierende Demokratie sie haben
demnach eine andere Vorstellung davon
was Politik leisten und um sollte bei
der vergangenen Bundestagswahl im Jahr
2021 sahen die Wahlergebnisse so aus
cdu/csu und SPD bekamen von ostby West
einen großen Anteil der Stimmen 24
Prozent der ostdeutschen Bevölkerung
wehte beispielsweise die SPD 26% der
westdeutschen Menschen ebenfalls das
macht deutlich Ost und West
unterscheiden sich nicht bei allen
Wahlergebnissen wesentlich auf der
zweiten Blick sticht aber etwas ins Auge
wenn man sich die Umfrageergebnisse zur
cdu/csu AFD der Linken und den Grünen
anschaut zeigen sich deutliche
ost-westunterschiede woran liegt diese
Verteilung und was können wir daraus
über das Demokratieverständnis der
ostdeutschen im Vergleich ablesen Andrea
Wolf schätzen sich zum Teil historisch
bedingt erklären sie lassen sich auch
ein bisschen erklären über gerade bei
der AFD über die Themen die im Wahlkampf
eine Rolle gespielt haben und ob es der
AFD gelungen ist die Proteststimmung
abzufangen und auch dann einzufangen
teststimmung ist ein ganz gutes
Stichwort Judith Enders von der Alis
salomon-hochschule Berlin ordnet die
Stimmung der ostdeutschen dahingehend so
ein ich würde sagen vielleicht ist es
die Reaktion darauf dass überhaupt
irgendwie der Staat Vorschriften machen
will zu einem Thema wo man sich
vermeintlich ja 1989 befreit hat in der
DDR gab es ja auch eine
demonstrations- und versammlungsrechte
aber die konnten halt nicht so ausgeübt
worden werden wie man wollte da gab es
sozusagen dann staatliche Repressionen
auf bestimmte Themen die man äußerte
wenn die nicht konform waren und so
weiter und ich glaube die Erinnerung
daran dass man eben nicht alles auf die
Straße bringen konnte oder sagen konnte
und dass man wirklich auch ernsthaft vom
Staat dann bedroht wurde schauen was die
Einstellungen der Ost und westdeutschen
mal in konkreten Situationen anhand von
Beispielen beim Thema Krieg in der
Ukraine geht das Verständnis davon wie
die Politik handeln sollte stark
auseinander auf die Frage soll
Deutschland der Ukraine moderne Kampf
Panzer liefern antworteten 67% der
ostdeutschen mit nein nur ein Viertel
ist dafür bei den Befragten im Westen
halten sich dagegen Zustimmung und
Ablehnung die Waage aber woher kommt
diese deutlich andere Haltung in dieser
Frage Judith Enders leitet das aus der
anderen Bindung der ostdeutschen
Menschen zu Russland her auf jeden Fall
gibt es in Ost und West sicherlichen
verschiedenes russlandbild es liegt
daran dass die ostdeutsche Kultur und
auch die ostdeutsche Bildungssystem und
also und sagen wir mal auch die
Erfahrung der der älteren
Familienmitglieder die haben eine viel
höhere Bindung in Russland oder an die
russische Kultur und an die Sowjetunion
als im Westen also der besten hat sich
immer Richtung Frankreich England
Amerika orientiert der Osten Richtung
Russland oder auch die anderen
osteuropäischen Staaten und Russland
waren ganz schwieriger schwieriger ein
großer Bruder ne wie große Brüder sind
irgendwie gefährlich und bedrohlich und
auch einer der gesagt hat wo es langgeht
und andererseits aber auch jemand an dem
man sich orientiert hat und ähm die
russische Kultur kenn man kennt Russen
ja also man kennt persönlich Russen die
nett sind mit der Studie 2020 2021 der
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung liefert noch
eine andere Erklärung ihre Ergebnisse
zeigen dass der Osten Deutschlands
stärkere rechtspopulistische Tendenzen
im Vergleich zum Westen aufweist
Rechtspopulismus bezeichnet im Übrigen
eine politische Strömung die autoritäre
Vorstellungen vertritt und rassistische
Vorurteile nutzt nicht immer ist
Rechtspopulismus in seinen Werten und
Ansichten scharf von Rechtsextremismus
zu unterscheiden die eben angesprochene
und übrigens auch immer wieder
kritisierte Mitte Studie stellt darüber
hinaus außerdem heraus besonders in
Krisenzeiten treten unterschiedliche
Verständnisse wie die Politik handeln
sollte deutlicher zu Tage und
Krisenzeiten begünstigen auch das vor
allem diese Unterschiede stärker in den
Blick genommen werden als die
Gemeinsamkeiten soweit erstmal ganz
logisch aber gibt es noch andere
Erklärungsansätze woher die stärkere
Unzufriedenheit und auch das andere
demokratieverständnisse im Osten kommen
wenn man über die Ursachen ostdeutscher
Unzufriedenheit spricht dann kommt man
um ein Thema nicht herum die deutsche
Wiedervereinigung man kann die Gefühle
und Punkte der ostdeutschen Bevölkerung
nicht nachvollziehen ohne verstanden zu
haben wie die Wände das Leben der
Menschen in Ostdeutschland verändert hat
denn genau das war es eine massive
Veränderung eine Zäsur in diesem
Zusammenhang spricht man auch von einem
transformationsschock das ist ein
ziemlich sperriger Begriff aber was
bedeutet das Transformation bedeutet zu
viel wie Übergang Wechsel und Schock
weil es ein massiver Einschnitt in das
Leben der ostdeutschen Menschen war und
diese Einschnitt bezieht sich auf die
Umstellung des Wirtschaftssystems die
sozialistische Planwirtschaft der DDR
wird innerhalb weniger Monate durch die
soziale Marktwirtschaft der
Bundesrepublik ersetzt inklusive
gemeinsame Währung und plötzlicher
westkonkurrenz für alle Waren und
Produkte viele man könnte auch sagen
sehr viele oder fast alle ostdeutschen
Betriebe hatten da keine Chance das
ostdeutsche Bruttoinlandsprodukt sind im
Jahr da Wiedervereinigung um 17,3% im
Folgejahr sogar um ganze 34,8 %. dazu
kommt dass die Hälfte der Erwerbstätigen
in Ostdeutschland nach der Wende
abwandert in den Vorruhestand geht oder
arbeitslos wird auf die erste Euphorie
über die Einheit folgt also der
ökonomische Abstieg für viele Menschen
in Ostdeutschland ist der Übergang zu
Demokratie also nicht verknüpft mit
einem Wirtschaftswunder wie in den
1950er Jahren in Westdeutschland sondern
mit dem Gegenteil dazu noch mal eine
Perspektive von Judith Enders von der
Ellis Salomon und Hochschule Berlin
ökonomischen Umbrüche kamen ziemlich
schnell und ziemlich radikal und man
kennt ja die Geschichten von den
Betriebsschließungen von dem dass die
Menschen im wichtigen Teil ihrer
Identität eingebüßt haben weil sie sehr
mit ihren Betrieben verbunden waren weil
sie arbeitslos wurden weil sie sich
geschämt haben bei Arbeitslosigkeit gab
es in dem Sinne in der DDR nicht und es
gab es auch nicht als Konstrukt im Kopf
was mache ich wenn ich arbeitslos bindet
war peinlich und schamhaft welche
genauen Auswirkungen der Wechsel des
politischen Systems auf die Menschen hat
ist wissenschaftlich schwierig
festzustellen auf jeden Fall
erschütterten die Umwälzungen die
ostdeutsche Gesellschaft massiv und
leiteten einen aufwühlenden Prozess ein
der bis heute anhält mehr dazu erfahrt
ihr auch in dem Video hier oben auf HDMI
die kann ich neue Werte annehmen ohne
dabei den Bezug zu meinen Wurzeln zu
verlieren eine von vielen Fragen die die
Menschen beschäftigt und in der sich
viele im Osten wohl zu wenig vom besten
verstanden fühlen das war für die
Menschen glaube ich sehr schmerzhaft
diese Abwertung der eigenen der eigenen
Kultur des Lebensstils selbst dessen das
ist eine fkk-kultur gab oder was sie
gegessen haben oder was ist wie Feste
gefeiert wurden alles wurde irgendwie so
abgewertet und es war wirklich ein
schlimmer Erfahrung für viele und die
Abwertung die kamen eindeutig aus dem
Westen also alles was am besten war war
gut und alles was DDR war war irgendwie
nicht gut das war so eine pauschale also
wie tabula rasa pauschal über
die gesamte
Lebenswelt sozusagen der DDR-Bürger
drüber gelegt eine künstlerische
Reflektion dieser Situation bietet ein
neuer Song von Finch materia und
Silbermond hört er mal rein
[Musik]
sind die vom letzten Platz die
man verdient
[Musik]
und dieses Gefühl ist nicht verstanden
werdens begleitet die ostdeutsche
Bevölkerung bis heute mehr als die
Hälfte der ostdeutschen fühlen sich eher
als Bürger zweiter Klasse das seht ihr
hier in einer Umfrage der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen vom September
2022 ja und dieses Gefühl ist nicht
verstanden werden dass auch in dem Song
ganz gut rüberkommt begleitet die
ostdeutsche Bevölkerung bis heute diese
Gefühle werden noch verstärkt wenn sich
die Ostdeutschen mit ihrer Geschichte
und Interessen nicht angemessen
vertreten fühlen die deutsche
Bundesregierung soll die gesamte
deutsche Gesellschaft repräsentieren das
ist ganz klar aber es sind 2022 nur zwei
der 17 Mitglieder des ampelkabinetts
ostdeutscher Herkunft obwohl 20% der
Bevölkerung aus Ostdeutschland stammt
das stellt eine ernstzunehmende
Schieflage da und dieses
repräsentationsproblem zieht sich durch
alle Gesellschaftsbereiche Politik klar
man kann darüber gesprochen aber auch
Wirtschaft Wissenschaft und auch Medien
dabei die großen Trends und
Herausforderungen für unser gesamtes
Land im Osten besonders ausgeprägt die
Überalterung der Gesellschaft zum
Beispiel andererseits sieht sich
Ostdeutschland auch als riesiges
zukunftslabor Tesla und Intel
investieren Milliarden und es gibt auch
jede Menge Platz für Neues ja wie ihr
gesehen habt ostdeutsche Seen politische
Entscheidungen und Handlungen oftmals
kritischer als die westdeutschen und das
liegt zum Teil an vielen
Herausforderungen mit denen die
ostdeutsche Bevölkerung seit der
Wiedervereinigung konfrontiert ist und
auch das weitreichende
repräsentationsproblemen scheint ein
Grund für das andere Verständnis von
einer funktionierende Demokratie zu sein
in der Ost wie West zu gleichen Maße
Teilhabe besitzen zum Schluss noch was
verbindendes das ist wichtig und davon
gibt es jede Menge zum Beispiel
befürworten mehr als 90% der deutschen
Bundesbürger aus wie West die deutsche
Einheit auch herrscht weitgehend
Einigkeit bei den großen
Problemstellungen unserer Gesellschaft
beispielsweise halten 51% der
westdeutschen und 45% der ostdeutschen
Themen rund um Energie Klima und Umwelt
für besonders wichtig verschiedene
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
zwischen 1995 und 2022 zeigen Ost- und
Westdeutschland werden sich immer
einiger 54% der befragten Deutschen im
September 2022 sind der Meinung dass es
mittlerweile mehr Gemeinsamkeiten als
Unterschiede zwischen Ost und
westdeutschen gibt wobei in der
ost-west-differenzierung 57% der
ostdeutschen Befragten mehr Unterschiede
wahrnehmen während die meisten Befragten
im Westen ebenfalls 57% mehr
Gemeinsamkeiten sehen heißt das also
dass man einen positiven Trend zu einem
stärkeren Gemeinschaftsgefühl von Ost
und Westdeutschland ablesen kann oder
gibt es noch eine
west-ost-schere wie ist das einzuordnen
dazu noch mal Andrea Wolf von der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen tendenziell kann
ich das schon ablesen ich kann ablesen
dass jetzt verglichen mit von vor 30
Jahren z.B dass die Gemeinsamkeiten
häufiger genannt werden als damals der
Fall war wir sind aber jetzt noch nicht
in Stadium wo es so von Umfrage zu
Umfrage kontinuierlich sich verändert
manchmal stagniert das auch ein bisschen
hängt wie eben schon besprochen auch
damit zusammen dass eben die die
aktuelle Situation gerade dazu führt
dass eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit da ist
und ich vielleicht nicht genug
wertgeschätzt fühle etc aber es ist auch
ganz interessant weil wenn wir in die
Altersgruppen schauen also etwas tiefer
hinter die Daten dann sieht man dass
jüngere befragte dass bei denen häufiger
die Gemeinsamkeiten im Vordergrund
stehen als bei älteren Befragten ja was
mich da mal interessieren würde ist
welche Berührungspunkte habt ihr denn
mit dem Thema welche Rolle spielt für
euch die Wiedervereinigung und die
entsprechenden Folgen kommt ihr
vielleicht das Ostdeutschland was habt
ihr von eure Eltern vielleicht auch ein
Großeltern gehört schreibt gerne unten
in die Kommentare und hier neben mir
findet ihr ein weiteres Video
Politbarometer to go und direkt darunter
etwas zum Leben in der DDR danke fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal